In the real world, bad things do happen, like files not being writeable or disks
being full. And we don't want our program to just crash one that happens, we
want to deal with it. Many programming languages, including Python, provide a
way of doing this and its called an exception. Here's an example of whats going
on. I'm going to open the file called blim.py to read from the current directory
and when I do this I get an error. The file didn't exist. And the error I got is
called an IOError. And it gives me a message. This is really a crash. I did this
in the Python interpreter, but if this happened inside a program, well, that
would end execution and we'd be done. If we want our programs to work or at
least fail gracefully in the real world where things like this can happen,
instead of allowing this failure to happen, what we need to do is catch it.
There's no way for open to return a file object, coz we asked for a file that
doesn't exist and that can't be read. So, there's no way to do this assignment.
We can imagine a different interface to open where it would return null or some
special object. And then, we'd have to test every time we did an open to see if
it worked. Since we assume it normally works, we don't have to do that test all
the time. Instead, we want to deal with fillers like this as exceptional cases.
So, here's what happened in the example, we're calling the open operation which
leads to call in the file module. Normally, that would return a file instance
which would be a sign to the variable f. In this case, something went wrong,
there's no file that can be returned. Instead, what happens is an exception will
be thrown. This isn't a normal return. So, execution doesn't continue as it
would with assignment, it continues somewhere else. Instead of being returned
normally, this exception doesn't continue execution normally, it gets caught by
an exception handler, if there is one. They can have more than five fingers. If
there are no exception handler, it causes the program to crash. And that's what
we saw in interpreter and I am sure you've seen programs that end in that type
of crash already. How do we make these handlers to try to prevent the program
from crashing? To do that, we need a try catch block. Here's the syntax, we use
try to introduce a block, anything that happens in that block, if it raises an
exception, it will jump to the exception handlers. If there's a handler that
matches the exception that was raised, and we'll talk more about how that
matching happens, then the exception handler will run. So, we can jump from
anywhere in the middle of this block, wherever an exception is raised to the
handler that handles that exception.